thanks to the Exorcist believer for
sponsoring today's video
[Music]
Yuri the show that'll turn its head
around 180 degrees for any scrapple lore
ladies and gentlemen it's time to get
dark
okay so it's not really all that rare of
an event here on the channels but you
know what is a rare event us talking
about one of the scariest most
influential horror franchises of all
time The Exorcist in case you don't know
this one these films check off all our
main criteria for a banger episode kids
check possessions check and that's the
list the original Exorcist back in the
day was a very important movie because
it legitimized the horror genre for
mainstream audiences while also given
the Chiropractic industry its first ever
viral video
oh just felt that one it also gave a
much needed boost to the Pea Soup makers
of the world
tasty and now this year a new chapter
begins The Exorcist believer releasing
in theaters on October 6th in this new
movie two teenage girls disappear for
three days and when they're found
something's changed they act strange
their personalities are a bit darker and
their parents eventually realize that in
true Exorcist fashion they've been
possessed by a demon in their Terror and
Desperation they seek out the only
person alive who's witnessed anything
like this before Chris McNeil mother to
Regan from the original story 50 years
ago so already you're dealing with a
tried and true premise except this time
it's multiplied by two truly Teamwork
Makes the Dream Work even in the realm
of demonic possession but then the
Exorcist believer decided to take it
another step further while the original
1973 was predominantly written from a
Catholic perspective on demonic
possession and exorcism believer brings
in the perspective from multiple faiths
Catholicism for sure but also the
Pentecostal Church the Baptist Church
even root medicine from Africa as Chris
McNeil says in the new movie exorcism is
one of the oldest human rituals every
culture in every country for as far back
as history has been recorded as a
ceremony to dispel negative energies and
that right there that is really cool
having the new movie feature exorcisms
across different belief systems it not
only educates the audience on multiple
faiths in a fun this doesn't even feel
like learning sort of way something that
you know we always stand on the theorist
channels but it also opens the door to
some intensely scary entities so I
wanted to do a bit of a thought
experiment today what if we take things
just a little step further the first
movie featured Regan getting possessed
by the Mesopotamian wind spirit Pazuzu
now this newest movies demonic entity is
introducing another Mesopotamian Spirit
known as lemashtu daughter of the sky
God and often depicted alongside Pazuzu
they are kind of like total besties with
lemash 2 causing nightmares attacking
pregnant women and corrupting bodies of
water in short these characters aren't
just being possessed by your regular old
Garden variety Satan they're very
specific demons from a very specific
time and place so if suddenly the doors
open for bringing another Faith what is
the biggest baddest possession entity
that we could face in a future
installment what are some other demons
and spirits that can make their Silver
Screen appearance in a future Exorcist
movie and which of them would present
the biggest challenge for any would-be
exorcists looking to bring them down
cause sometimes holy water and Crosses
just aren't enough basically I want to
know who would be the final boss of The
Exorcist films hold your crucifix close
and start praying loyal theorists the
power compels ya to keep watching also
right off the bat I want to say that
what we're covering today are real
faiths held by real people with an
incredible amount of nuance detail and
Regional difference I want to make it
perfectly clear that this is a very top
line surface level discussion that's
meant to be fun while sparking some
creative interest in spooky stuff we
just think it'd be cool to see some of
these spirits and their faiths
represented on screen and of course when
that would happen the filmmakers would
consult people of those faiths to ensure
that everything is authentic I just want
to flag that since you know this is a
short online video that's touching on
religion and Faith so just keep that in
mind as we roll forward the first faith
I wanted to bring in here today is Islam
considering it's one of the most
practiced religions on the planet with
nearly 25 percent of Earth's population
identifying as Muslim and while not all
Muslims believe in exorcisms or rookaya
as they call them there are plenty of
stories that have circulated throughout
the faith for instance there was one
story from 2021 that involved a married
couple in Jakarta moving into a home
haunted by evil the wife becoming
possessed and the couple turning to
three Muslim experts to perform an
exorcism so what could potentially be
doing The Possession here but within
Islam There Are Spiritual creatures
known as Jinn probably better known by
their other name Genies yeah you heard
that right but hold your Robin Williams
there friends these are not your typical
celebrity impersonating blue wisps of
smoke in fact there are many different
types appearing across hundreds of
different stories in the Quran alone
there are 29 different mentions of Jinn
but records of their existence actually
date back to pre-islamic Arabia Jinn in
general don't tend to be innately good
or evil instead they tend to have free
Free Will and can thus decide on their
moral course of action that said there
are a few in the stories that are
explicitly called out as being evil the
afrit for instance are beings of Fire
coming from the underworld there's also
the shaitan evil Devils that lack free
will but work to tempt humans to sin and
these Jinn are known to possess humans
though the reasons can vary drastically
it could be as simple as the human
offended them or the Jinn just wanted to
cause trouble to them falling in love
with a human and wanting to be loved in
return sometimes even Spirits aren't
immune to toxic relationships so that's
what we're dealing with but if we're
truly gonna identify which is the final
boss of exorcism we need to know how to
evict these guys from our bodies modern
strategies for dealing with gin amount
to reciting verses from the Quran
nothing too extreme there according to
Georgetown University associate
professor Amira elzen pre-islamic Arabs
would use a combination of beads incense
salt and necklaces made from the bones
and teeth of animals to frighten Jin
away again pretty easy stuff to come by
according to one study which looked
across various exorcisms performed by
Arab Muslim Healers they found that
exorcisms tended to be divided up into
three stages step one remove all
distractions including music jewelry and
pictures step two cleanse the room and
try to communicate with the Gin about
their reason for The Possession then
finally step three recite the Quran and
ask the Jinn to leave and uh yeah that
is basically it not to be too reductive
here guys but gin honestly they're
pretty casual clean up the room a bit
you talk about their problems and then
you ask them to go away they just need
to be heard guys they want to vent you
know and interestingly enough I saw this
theme pop up a lot across my research in
the story of the fisherman and the Ginny
part of the Famous folk tales from 1001
Nights a fisherman finds a bottle
containing an afrit the afried threatens
to kill the fisherman but the fisherman
manages to negotiate a peaceful
resolution that gets both the fishermen
and the Gin what they want seriously an
exorcist negotiating with a gin and both
parties walking away with a win-win
scenario sounds more like a conflict
resolution meeting with HR than the big
final bad of some spooky exorcism story
so what other cultures have a Rich
history of demons and possessions that
we can draw from well next up on the
world tour is the Shinto the indigenous
religion of Japan a faith that holds a
lot of reverence for nature and the
spirits that inhabit it finish until
practices seek to communicate with and
appease those Spirits so you can already
see how this might fit in with an
exorcist story see in Shintoism everyone
has a reikon similar to The Western idea
of a spirit or a soul however when
someone dies suddenly their raccoon can
struggle to move on instead transforming
into a yurai similar to The Western
concept of a ghost the yodai are often
driven by very powerful emotions Revenge
jealousy love sorrow and it's through
resolving that emotional conflict that
the spirit can finally be laid to rest
another interesting option here is
appealing to the spirit's ego I found
one story where the 12th century Emperor
satoku died and became a vengeful Spirit
haunting his court only for them to
exercise him by treating him like a
demigod this calmed him enough that his
Spirit ultimately departed so yet again
we get ourselves an exorcism scenario
that's less about throwing holy water at
a child doing crab walks on the ceiling
and more about having a cup of tea with
someone on the couch to talk about their
feelings it's not exactly big screen
worthy stuff but while we're busy having
tea and cakes with the yurai there is
another class of Supernatural entities
that could lead to far more unique forms
of exorcism those are known as the Yokai
and though the word can translate
literally to demon they're not really
demons in the western sense of the word
instead they're more like spirits that
represent natural parts of the world or
phenomenon that can't be explained as
such there are hundreds of different
Yokai each with their own personality
for example tsukumo gami are possessed
tools ranging from futons and mirrors to
shoes and jars while other Yokai like
Kitsune Fox Spirits have been known to
possess human beings and cause them to
take on the physical characteristics of
a fox so how then would an exorcist deal
with these Yokai the sort of general
term for a Shinto exorcism or
purification is harai which is meant to
cleanse one of their sins bad luck
diseases and guilt along with exercising
any Spirits possessing them one common
way of doing this water water and
especially fresh clean water is believed
to have purifying properties that can
wash away evil and restore balance we're
talking things like washing hands
pouring water over the body rinsing out
your mouth basically you're treating the
Yokai like a case of coven 19. stay
healthy and hashtag stop the spread of
mischievous spirits that said there are
other more elaborate ceremonies known as
misogi that can be used for particularly
stubborn Spirits these feature
participants dressing in special white
garments and gathering in sacred places
like shrines and waterfalls to chant
meditate and pray away the Yokai the
possessed person is immersed in cold
water to cleanse away any impurities
while the rituals perform which involves
a lot of clapping bowing and prayer to
try and drive out the possessing demon
but if that's still not enough well
thankfully there's tools that the trade
to use if things become more
confrontational these include the afuda
a sort of Talisman made from paper or
cloth meant to keep people in places
safe the gohe wooden wands with
zigzagging paper streamers representing
the presence of the Divine and the
katana a traditional Japanese sword
symbolizing power and strength allowing
The Exorcist to cut through negative
energies and Exorcist with a sword huh
but that one on your next Blockbuster
movie poster that is awesome however
across all my research there was one
spirit that truly stood out as the
biggest and baddest of the bunch one
that appears to be far more violent and
far more fearsome than the rest the
definitive final boss of any Exorcist
story hailing from Native American
folklore specifically coming from the
indigenous peoples of the Plains and
Great Lakes I'm talking about the
wendigo now the thing about the windigo
is that they have been misappropriated
to heck and back by a lot of mainstream
media so what is with the windigo
exactly well the way to go is
traditionally speaking a spirit of
winter and a symbol of the dangers of
selfishness it's often said to be a
malevolent Spirit which sometimes
chooses to possess human beings invoking
feelings of insatiable greed and hunger
probably the most iconic trait of the
spirit is that it causes the victim to
turn cannibal despite their depiction as
creatures similar to werewolves or yetis
and a lot of Pop Culture according to
most native Legends the physical form of
the windigo is actually very human-like
often times with hearts of ice someone
described the windigo as having bodies
entirely made of ice there gaunt and
emaciated so hungry for human flesh
they've chewed their own lips off
whenever a windigo would eat another
person they would grow in proportion to
what they just consumed so they could
never truly be full it also means that
over time windigos grow to be gigantic
so how does one become possessed by a
windigo well there's actually a few
methods you could be specifically cursed
by a shaman you can encounter a windigo
in your dreams where it follows you into
the real world or probably the most
common method I've seen floating around
is that it's punishment for some sort of
dishonorable act breaking a major taboo
like resorting to cannibalism during a
time of starvation so what do we know
about exercising a wendigo Spirit well
here's the thing in almost every case I
could find you can't once someone
becomes possessed and transformed into a
wendigo there's no coming back this
isn't a sit down on the couch and talk
about your feelings kind of possession a
quick mouth rinse with water ain't
washing this one away the solution and
the stories that I read was to kill the
possessed so they can't continue their
cannibalistic murder Rampage it is that
hardcore in short the wendigo is a
spirit that cannot be exercised advised
which honestly is pretty darn horrifying
even more horrifying though is that this
isn't just something that exists in
folklore it is a real thing there's
actually a modern psychiatric condition
that borrows its name from these stories
it's called windigo psychosis and it's
characterized by an intense fear of
becoming a cannibal while suffering from
intense cravings for human flesh first
off that right there that could play
really well in some sort of Exorcist
story with the windigo Spirit maybe some
of the characters are suffering from
this windigo psychosis without actually
being possessed mixing in a bit of
mystery as to who's the one truly in
need of help but diving even more deeply
into the psychosis I did find treatments
of the condition in some Cree folklore
here they ate fatty animal meat and
drank animal grease in an attempt to
drive the psychosis out of the patient
as the stories go some of the people who
are treated this way would allegedly
vomit up ice as part of the curing
process given that the windigo the
spirit of winter is supposed to have a
heart made of ice a pretty easy
connection to draw there maybe the
carrot is literally throwing up the ice
heart of the windigo so in total across
our spiritual battle we have talk about
out your feelings wash your hands throw
up a heart made of ice I think I know
which on that list is going to be the
most difficult to accomplish wendigo
wins The Exorcist battle hands down at
this point you could probably tell Chris
McNeil was 100 right in The Exorcist
believer when she said that every
culture on Earth has purification
rituals like exorcisms each as intricate
and unique as the last just from these
three cultures alone we have wildly
different spirits that can all possess
you in different ways with markedly
different strategies of exorcism and
that was without even touching on the
faiths that were represented in The
Exorcist believer that's because you
should probably go see it for yourself
when the film comes out in theaters this
Friday I certainly know I'll be there
hiding behind my hands these movies are
scary man but until then remember my
friends it's all just a theory a film
Theory and cuts
thank you